I made a square hole in this sheet of paper,
And a coaster, a round coaster.
I fold the paper in a mysterious way,
And I can get the coaster through the hole.
It really goes both ways
And I didn't start cheating.
It really goes through the hole.
And yet, when I turn it off,
the diameter of the coaster is larger than the diagonal of the square hole.
What is going on? I have not stretched it and I have not torn it.
And yet when I fold the sheet back,
in a sensible way,
does the coaster go through,
The coaster that is larger than the hole.
How is this possible?
I am willing to give away the secret for free during this special occasion
It has to do with the interaction between,
the intrinsic, or inner dimension, of the sheet of paper that is 2 dimensions.
And the fact that the skin evolves and flourishes in the surrounding three-dimensional space.
There is an elbow room, there is some ambient space.
So dimension 2 and dimension 3.
In the following sense.
First, I can fold the paper in a naive way as follows,
in which case the largest opening I can try to let the disk through is this space.
That was previously, as you can see,
the diagonal of the square hole
And that was too small to let the disk through.
But that's not the only thing we do.
Now I take this sheet of paper and start turning it
until those two sides are aligned in a straight line
And while I do this, while turning the ends
you can see that the part of the paper is starting to rise above the floor.
That is escape to the 3rd dimension,
take advantage of the fact that there is extra space there.
And when those two sides fully align
Then I can crush and fold.
And by the way, if I do, I have to exchange one
to create this space.
The space that we created then is this space,
which is larger than the previous space,
because this hole was not the diagonal, but the sum of those two sides.
And if you still remember Pythagoras,
you have received an extra square root factor of 2, which is slightly more than 40%.
So the secret to success when you make this toy
is to make the hole,
so that the diagonal is slightly shorter than the diameter of the disc for the surprise,
but the sum of the two sides is slightly longer than this diameter.
And that is possible, because there is 40% extra space.
And this is all possible, because if we perform this maneuver
allow the whole thing to come out in 3D and then come back down.
This fact that you can escape to the surrounding 3rd dimension and come back,
this extra step that you take towards the extra degree of freedom
gives you this beautiful magic.
[ROBOT NOISES]